uh
let me start by saying i've seen the
first nine episodes
of season five and it is spectacular
um loved the season uh and my guess my
biggest complaint and i want to talk
about this
is um why can't it be more than ten
episodes
honest to god every time i see other
series other tv series that are more
than ten episodes i keep thinking
why can't we do that because every novel
is like 600 700 pages
but uh i understand that there has to be
like certain numbers
it can't be more sure
me too because it's like you know when
we like a story
when we're listening to a story or
watching a story when we like it
we want it to continue and we think that
and especially when the story has
leveraged to do so
we you and i know these novels have the
leverage to do
like 20 episodes or even maybe 24
episodes a year
but i guess there's a limit too yeah
i actually i understand the the the i
understand why it's ten episodes
um i get it it's just uh they're so well
done it's just such a good season but
um i know you i can't talk about
spoilers or anything but what are you
allowed to say
about what happens in season five what
happens in season five
is really the consequences of what took
place in season one
she's on the roof of the sword
taking rest gazing
the stars her grandson joins her
and asks her are you afraid of the rocks
and she says no i'm not afraid of the
rocks i'm afraid of the people
who throw the rocks so you see
how dense how convinced this this
saga these 800 700 600 pages
novels uh have turned into
a uh a world on its own
like we when i was a kid i imagined life
on mars
now i look at life in the expanse
and it's like it's inevitable i've
obviously after sending a shuttle to the
moon
in uh before you know 2000 but obviously
we're gonna get that in 200 years
in 300 years i live on mars or do not
work
so it it really
it's really like like real life a work
in progress
completely um one of the things i think
season five one of the reasons season
five is so good
is that over the past few seasons uh you
know people have come to love
and uh love the characters on the series
and this season
everyone is so spread out um and i think
that adds to the series because
everyone's allowed to have their sort of
their own little adventures can you sort
of talk about that aspect of the season
you mean um the um uh
can you elaborate on this oh sure the
fact that like eat
in in previous seasons i think more
people were were together um
in this one people are spread out in
places they have not
normally been oh i see what you mean yes
exactly
i call it a roller coaster like when
we're all together
at our height and then all of a sudden
um
everything goes wrong and all that this
house of course
comes out so uh again
just right like in real life uh
we see people uh getting
upset trying to take revenge or
um literally speaking they they become
ineffective because they feel like
they're not doing anything right
but uh um what i love about this one
is that it's all about
making the world work
together because and this this reminds
me of the politics
that when i started um studying politics
back in the uk 40 years ago
i really read a lot about churchill and
his idea of
divide and rule and it it
may have worked 100 years ago but it's
not working anymore
therefore we really need to find new
ways
of and there is not no way that
we can do it alone we need together
to get together and do it together and
make the world a better place to live in
this i know we have said this so many
times that it
has turned into a cliche now but it
shouldn't really
because we haven't done much yet but
uh what happens in the experience just
like
mirroring the real life people are
together
ten heads work for one head think for
one head
but then they notice that unfortunately
in being tribal there's a danger in
being tribal
and the danger is that if one person
is not happy with what is happening that
person
can put the whole world on fire
yep 100 percent transparency
i mean diplomacy and then let's make
let's choose our our people make sure
who we talk to
and yeah um i normally don't bring this
up with people
however uh the outfits you wear on this
series
are fantastic um which of them did you
quote unquote borrow
to take home i never buy one
i never borrow my costumes uh
never ask for them uh because
i just uh usually i'm done with the
movie
i'm done with the series and i'm like
okay i had a
great time with you goodbye time to wear
new clothes
but in this one i am dying to bring one
one costume home and that's the uh
elaborate gown at the
martian dinner got it
because i know some of them are going uh
gonna go to the museum
uh the television academy museum for
sure
some of them are are just out of this
world uh they have taken like
hours one of them i remember the
inverted took
three days for three people
working on it so i know it's not easy to
let go one and let go
this is probably my last question um uh
like everyone i am
really i'm super sad that season six is
gonna be the last season of this
series but i also love that amazon saved
the show
and i love that they're letting everyone
know in advance that this is gonna be
the last season
um what are you what are you feeling
knowing that there's just one more
season of the series
and can you talk about sort of like the
end of it to be honest with you
day one and wes always
reminds me of this that a day one they
took us
for a tour of the set it was before we
even started
uh filming uh they put us two by two you
know on the line and we started
they gave us safety hands and we started
touring
the set we look at the rossi the shot
i don't know why i know what i turned
around
looked at wes and i said we were told
we were hired for one year i turned
around looked at this and i said
five to six years
[Music]
we had a panel and he mentioned it again
he said how did you know
that it's going to take six years i said
if you recall i said five to six because
i wasn't sure
but uh and we are very thankful
to amazon for picking this up for
allowing us
to arrive uh at season six
but tell you the truth i don't think
that story is finished here
yeah i i don't want it to be so whatever
you know hopefully there's more
my instinct tells me this is not the end
i don't know how to
it's exactly the same way as when i
looked at rossi and i said
minimum five to six years which wes
loves to do it
he does a great job and he does my
accent minimum of five or six years
less which is i don't know but i have a
feeling that
no we are going to tell this story till
the end
how did i know that amazon was going to
pick us up
when we were cancelled but i have a
feeling that
this is not the end